Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en que
los periodistas son los invitados y
conversamos sobre los hechos que han
marcado la actualidad de la semana hoy
hablamos del decreto de muerte Cruzada
en Ecuador de la gira internacional de
followski de los derechos lgbt y q más
en el continente americano y de la
polémica desatada por la apertura del
festival de can con una película
protagonizada por Johnny Depp
acompáñenos con sus opiniones
comentarios y preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales arroba franz24 - alpiso
es numeral una semana en el mundo
empezamos ahora saludando a nuestros
invitados Y es que desde quito Contamos
con Fabricio vela él es periodista de
radio sonorama portal Primera Plana y
canal rtu Fabricio Bueno le saludo desde
los estudios de France 24 en Bogotá le
preguntó cómo termina la semana con Qué
noticias una pregunta que puede parecer
un poco obvia desde Ecuador pero
confirmemos
Hola Saludos cordiales desde Quito
Ecuador muy honrado de participar de
este espacio Bueno no es una pregunta
tan obvia porque seguramente desde el
exterior se puede pensar que al momento
hay un clima hostil en el Ecuador de
inestabilidad de protestas y debo
decirles que dos días después de que el
presidente Guillermo lasso decretara la
disolución del poder legislativo acá en
el Ecuador de un hecho inédito que no
tiene precedentes en la historia
política ecuatoriana no tenemos
protestas
la asamblea está cerrada la función
legislativa está cerrada acordonada por
militares pero no hay protestas no hay
un clima de hostilidad en las calles el
sector público está trabajando
normalmente al igual que el sector
privado y digamos la semana se cierra
así con algo de tranquilidad en medio de
esta situación política atípica en el
Ecuador Fabricio ahora volveremos con
esta situación atípica en Ecuador pero
antes saludamos desde Madrid a Enrique
Rodríguez él es corresponsal en España
de Blu radio Enrique le preguntó a usted
lo mismo Qué temas lo han mantenido
ocupado hasta este viernes
Bueno pues el tema de cuadros uno de los
temas que de los que más he hablado aquí
en España seguramente porque bueno con
toda seguridad porque en España hay un
importante Colonia ecuatoriana Y eso
hace que cualquier cosa que pase en
Ecuador máxime cuando es una cosa como
esta que está generando Pues esa tensión
política y esa sensación de
inestabilidad que parece que acompaña
siempre a los gobiernos de Ecuador pues
se sigue con mucho interés evidentemente
hablaremos de otros temas se sigue
hablando aquí en Europa de la Guerra de
Ucrania y de otras muchas cosas pero lo
que está pasando en Ecuador si si hay
una sensación de
de no entender muy bien Qué es lo que
está pasando esa especie de de maniobra
que ha tomado el presidente de Ecuador
pero sobre todo la pregunta que se hacen
hoy los periódicos aquí en España es A
quién va a beneficiar esta maniobra si
va a beneficiar a quien convoca
elecciones o si por ejemplo la izquierda
de Rafael Correa a su partido de su
satélite va a verse beneficiado con
motivo de esta de esta decisión que ha
tomado el presidente lazo Bueno pues
ahora vamos a intentar entender
exactamente lo que está sucediendo en
Ecuador pero antes vamos con un breve
contexto sobre lo que pasó el pasado
miércoles 17 de mayo cuando el
presidente Guillermo lasso decretó la
llamada muerte cruzado muerte Cruzada un
mecanismo que reposa en el artículo 148
de la Constitución para disolver la
asamblea nacional y convocar elecciones
anticipadas de este modo lasso evitó un
juicio político en su contra por
supuesta malversación Fabricio empiezo
por usted se lo esperaba
sí debo ser categórico en esto sí estaba
en el radar de el análisis y de los
pronósticos de la política ecuatoriana
la posibilidad de que el presidente lazo
decrete este mecanismo popularmente
conocido como muerte Cruzada que es
invocar la capacidad constitucional de
disolver la función legislativa por una
sola vez algo muy parecido y lo pongo en
contexto lo que ocurrió hace pocos meses
en el Perú aunque con diferencias sobre
lo que dice la norma constitucional en
el Perú Pedro Castillo hizo lo propio
digamos rebasando los límites
constitucionales lacio invoca el
artículo 148 de la Constitución y
Resuelve la asamblea señalando la causal
de grave crisis política y conmoción
interna hace ruido porque ocurre cuando
se llevaba adelante el primer día del
juicio político lazo había concurrido
previamente la asamblea nacional lazo en
una exposición de cuarenta y nueve
minutos se defendió de una acusación de
supuesto peculado
y al final de su intervención llamó al
diálogo al al a la asamblea al congreso
ecuatoriano y a los legisladores
despidió de poner posiciones y trabajar
juntos por eh solucionar los graves
problemas del Ecuador
su llamado No no tuvo eco ciertamente en
el curso del debate del del juicio
político y al día siguiente amanecemos
muy temprano con la noticia de la
disolución del poder legislativo
y la asamblea ya no tuvo tiempo de votar
no tuvo tiempo de continuar con este
proceso el presidente adopta una
decisión de un tema del cual se venía
hablando desde octubre del año 2021 por
primera vez ya se habló de la muerte
Cruzada en octubre del año 2021 y
sucesivamente en varios espacios de
diferencias entre El Ejecutivo y el
legislativo se volvía a hablar de la
aplicación de la denominada muerte
Cruzada a mí lo personal me sorprendió
Más allá de estos antece es porque el
día martes al final de la jornada diez
de la noche cuando se cerró esa jornada
y quedaba un segundo día de debates y de
liberaciones de los congresistas en el
cálculo no había votos o sea era poco
probable que se completen los 92 votos
para proceder a la censura de
distribución del presidente de la
república entonces con ese panorama
digamos había salido del del pronóstico
inmediato que al día siguiente el
presidente decrete la disolución de la
asamblea nacional por eso mismo nos
sorprendió justamente esta decisión Del
mandatario sí Fabricio y lazo justificó
su decisión de hecho en una entrevista
con el diario El País diciendo
literalmente he escogido gobernar seis
meses en el purgatorio en lugar de dos
años en el infierno no a pesar de que
reconocía eso que quizás no había votos
para llevar adelante ese juicio político
Enrique le planteó lo mismo desde España
sorprendió esta decisión
Sí claro sorprende porque evidentemente
el mecanismo aquí es completamente
desconocido no no tiene una equiparación
en en la política española ni en la
Constitución española pero conociendo un
poco la realidad de Ecuador sorprende
por lo que estábamos comentando porque
es la primera vez que se invoca un
mecanismo como este y desde luego Más
allá de la legalidad que la tiene y eso
no no parece que haya ningún
cuestionamiento a ese respecto lo que sí
pone sobre la mesa es si esto no supone
también una cierta debilidad
institucional porque cuando se está
enfrentando a una suerte de juicio
político el mandatario del país puede
usar esta estratagema para evitarlo
evidentemente eso lo que hace es que ese
juicio político en la práctica sea
impracticable si se me permite la
redundancia ahora bien
hay una cierta tranquilidad por lo que
nos estaban contando desde allá Desde
Ecuador no hay una cierta tranquilidad
sabiendo que no ha habido disturbios que
no parece que vaya a haber disturbios
pero evidentemente
la sensación que hay aquí Tal vez no sea
confesada y evidentemente ni siquiera el
gobierno español ni la diplomacia
española se ha pronunciado en ese
sentido el temor es que se habla un
periodo convulso en estos meses que le
quedan al frente del del país hasta que
se convoquen las elecciones a lazo
quiero decir que esa sensación hay de
que de que sí puede ser un momento
convulso y cómo se van a celebrar esas
elecciones Y de nuevo como señalaba
antes otra de las grandes cuestiones es
A quién va a beneficiar esta medida si
si a lazo le va a dar un beneficio
electoral si luego se lo va a dar a la
oposición a los partidos de izquierda
son muchas incógnitas y bien Es verdad
que si bien la realidad latinoamericana
siempre es poliédrica y a veces difícil
de entender por por lo difícil los
distintos que son las legislaciones y
los sistemas constitucionales y
presidenciales en Latinoamérica este
mecanismo lo ves aún más porque como
como decía al inicio es un mecanismo que
no tiene parangón en las legislaciones
europeas sí Enrique y ahora abordaremos
en un momento el panorama en el que
llegarán estas elecciones anticipadas
Pero antes Fabricio Le quiero preguntar
precisamente por este periodo que se
abre entre esta disolución de la
asamblea nacional y la convocatoria la
realización de hecho de las nuevas
elecciones que se prevén para el mes de
agosto en este tiempo el lazo va a
gobernar por decreto con la vigilancia
de la corte constitucional Qué medidas
se espera que él lleve a cabo en estos
meses
la propia Constitución establece un un
ámbito muy cerrado para la emisión de
los decretos leyes por parte del
ejecutivo presidente lazo solamente
puede gobernar emitiendo decretos leyes
en materia económica previo el aval de
la corte constitucional de hecho ya
emitió el primero que es una reforma
tributaria para eh facilitar el retorno
de las deducciones de gastos personales
para el pago del impuesto a la renta
tema que fue eliminado en una reforma
que él mismo propuso en el año 2021 y se
anuncia un segundo decreto que tiene que
ver con el manejo de las zonas francas
para los temas de comercio exterior en
ambos casos la corte constitucional
Todavía no se ha pronunciado sobre el
primer caso ya fue enviado ese decreto
ley a la corte constitucional que no
tiene un plazo específico para
pronunciarse pero por ejemplo estaba
pendiente en la asamblea nacional
a punto de ser aprobada una reforma a la
Constitución para posibilitar la
participación de las fuerzas armadas en
tareas de Seguridad Ciudadana de forma
complementaria con la Policía Nacional
la Constitución solo permite que los
militares puedan coexistir con la
policía cuando hay estados de excepción
o Estados de emergencia la idea era
reformar la Constitución para que
siempre previas algunas condiciones los
militares puedan apoyar a la Policía
Nacional esa reforma quedó allí estaba a
punto de ser aprobada pero no fue
aprobada por la asamblea y el presidente
no la puede poner en vigencia porque eso
rebasa su capacidad constitucional por
poner justamente Este ejemplo entonces
Habría que ver qué tipo de medidas toma
El Ejecutivo en el ámbito económico han
hablado una reforma laboral esto podría
eventualmente generar un calentamiento
de calles si es que esa reforma laboral
tiene algún tipo de afectación que pueda
generar el descontento de los sindicatos
y de los grupos sociales estamos también
pendientes de los temas de la minería
por ejemplo o del sector petrolero que
podrían provocar un calentamiento de
calles por parte del movimiento indígena
estos dos sectores sindicatos e
indígenas están en una suerte de compás
de espera la conaye que es el grupo
indígena más grande del Ecuador se va a
reunir el próximo veinticinco de mayo
para tomar decisiones los sindicatos
Igualmente están expectantes digamos
esto como un panorama previo a lo que se
podría generar en las próximas semanas
dependiendo de lo que resuelve el
presidente lasso en materia de decretos
ejecutivos y precisamente en relación a
esta espera por parte de grupos sociales
como de la conaya que ustedes bien
mencionaba Fabricio
sorprende quizás desde fuera que no haya
habido protestas después de esta
disolución de la asamblea nacional Cómo
se explica
mi lectura sobre la ausencia de
protestas es que hay una expectativa que
se ha abierto en torno al desarrollo de
la selección es decir hoy en el Ecuador
anoche ya quedó en firme la disolución
de la asamblea con un fallo de la corte
constitucional y al día de hoy el
Consejo Nacional electoral ya está
adelantando lo que podría ser su
calendario que será confirmado entre el
23 y 24 de mayo la próxima semana o sea
la expectativa que hay es que las
elecciones las tenemos a la vuelta de la
esquina en tres meses más menos el 20 de
agosto Ecuador irá elecciones para
elegir nuevo presidente y vicepresidente
y nueva asamblea nacional mi lectura es
esa mi lectura es que entramos en un
compás de espera por la cercanía del
proceso electoral Sí y ya nos quedamos
sin mucho tiempo para abordar este tema
pero le traslado la pregunta a Enrique
precisamente Qué diferencias se ven con
lo sucedido en Perú el 7 de diciembre
cuando fue Pedro Castillo quien la
disolvió el parlamento Y ahí sí después
de su arresto se desataron masivas
protestas que duraron a meses
Esa es la diferencia fundamental aquí
Más allá de las particularidades
políticas ilegales de de cada territorio
que insisto son aquí a veces ajenas y
desconocidas lo que sí se mira con
tranquilidad es precisamente eso es
decir el hecho de que no haya protesta
eso no quiere decir mejor lo sabe
nuestro compañero en Ecuador eso no
quiere decir que no las vaya a ver en el
futuro pero evidentemente que haya esa
tranquilidad esa situación de
tranquilidad si aporta también valga la
redundancia algo de tranquilidad a
quienes desde aquí observan el fenómeno
insisto la comunidad ecuatoriana es
abundantísima Es una de las más
importantes aquí en territorio español y
en otros países europeos hay muchos
representantes de Ecuador puede ser por
ejemplo el caso de Italia y por eso se
mira con muchísimo interés lo que está
pasando bueno Fabricio Enrique seguro
tendremos muchos días para analizar como
el país llega a estas elecciones
anticipadas ahora Les propongo que
cambiemos de tema con otra que marca la
actualidad de los últimos días sino de
los últimos meses y hablamos de la
guerra en Ucrania pero particularmente
hablamos de que el presidente voló dimix
de lensky se encuentra en plena gira
internacional acaba de estar en cheda en
Arabia Saudita para dirigirse a la liga
árabe y se espera su participación en el
g7 que se celebra en Hiroshima esto
después de estar en los últimos días en
Roma en el Vaticano en Berlín en París y
en Londres en busca sobre todo de más
armamento para su país salió del búnker
y él lleva así su presencia
internacional al máximo nivel digamos
les pregunto como profesionales de la
comunicación empezó por usted Enrique
Cuál es la estrategia mediática de
comunicación política detrás de estos
movimientos
Pues mira por encima de todo lo primero
que se puede ver en esta estrategia Más
allá de las reuniones que tenga de dónde
hable o con quién se vea lo primero que
deja claro vuelo de selensky es que si
bien al principio nos parecía que no
podía salir de Ucrania que su vida corre
peligro y su vida siempre corre peligro
pero como que estaba encerrado en
Ucrania ya la sensación no es esa vemos
que puede salir y entrar del país no con
normalidad pero sí con facilidad Y eso
evidentemente tiene un enorme valor
simbólico para Ucrania pero también para
Rusia que que evidentemente detrás de
todo lo que está pasando en Ucrania hay
una enorme fracaso militar por parte de
Rusia que presumía de tener el segundo
ejército más importante del mundo y
seguramente sea el segundo más numeroso
o el tercero Pero evidentemente ha
demostrado en muchos aspectos ser un
cascarón vacío pero volviendo a bolodo
mirt selensky su estrategia Es evidente
es implicar de la mayor manera posible a
la comunidad internacional su viaje a
hablar con la liga árabe de hecho decir
al presidente sirio va a ser no
decírselo directamente pero sí de manera
indirecta en el discurso que pronunció
que ya estaba bien de apoyar a Rusia en
Clara referencia a él y sus encuentros
del pasado fin de semana el más
fructífero seguramente fue esta misma
semana con el Primer Ministro británico
con risa sunat de allí sacó un
importante paquete de mejora de
armamentos lo que no ha logrado con con
estos viajes ni con sus reuniones y no
parece que lo vaya a obtener a la
reunión del g7 es una de las cosas que
lleva haciendo desde casi el inicio de
esta guerra que es apoyo militar en
forma de aeronave eso Por el momento no
la ha conseguido ha conseguido sistemas
de misiles que están funcionando
francamente bien en Ucrania sistemas de
drones sistemas de artillería pero no ha
logrado que occidente se preste a a
darle a aeronaves por motivos varios
seguramente el primero de ellos es el
gran coste que tienen esos elementos y
el entrenamiento que necesitarían los
pilotos ucranianos sí Enrique
precisamente Esta es la siguiente
cuestión que quería abordar y Fabricio
te invito a que plantee su opinión al
respecto Y es que hace instantes se ha
conocido en el marco de esta Cumbre del
g7 que Estados Unidos finalmente acepta
entrenar pilotos ucranianos en el uso de
los caza de estos aviones de combate
f-16 que tanto solicitas elenski con
estas frases de aviones para Ucrania a
las para la libertad sin embargo de
momento tal y como publicaba el New York
Times como decíamos a la raíz de esta
noticia Se desconoce qué país va a
proveer finalmente estos aviones de
combate Y es que la otan teme una
escalada y ser un poco visto como co
beligerante en el conflicto Cómo se
espera que Rusia reaccione a esta
noticia hay que recordar que este
conflicto ya Data de de más de un año no
y cuando comienza el conflicto hubo
sectores y gente especializada que
vaticinaba que esto podría desembocar en
una conflagración muchísimo más grande
una conflagración planetaria lo que
feliz ocurrido pero Permítame Añadir a
esta conversación algo que en su momento
fue noticia aquí en el Ecuador porque
Ecuador de alguna manera también tuvo
algún tipo de incidencia dentro de lo
que está ocurriendo en este conflicto
entre Rusia y Ucrania y es que el pasado
catorce de abril aquí en el Ecuador se
armó toda una discusión por una
publicación del de New York Times
respecto de un documento filtrado en
donde Ecuador habría considerado la
posibilidad de enviar armamento Ucrania
Esto fue desmentido por el gobierno
ecuatoriano pues metido por el canciller
y no se hizo mayor ruido pero lo publicó
el de New York Times había reportes
filtrados de inteligencia de los Estados
Unidos que daban cuenta que el gobierno
del presidente Guillermo lasso sí
estudió la posibilidad de enviar al
momento a las tiendas ucranianas en el
contexto de la invasión Rusia rusa está
claro que el gobierno sobre este tema el
gobierno ecuatoriano tomó una decisión y
es tomar partido a favor de Ucrania por
supuesto Ecuador frente
a los países de la otan O a los países
europeos más cercanos digamos tiene una
opinión muchísimo más tangencial pero es
una postura que la asumió el gobierno
del presidente lazo y por eso generó
mucho ruido sobre todo en la oposición
esta noticia que no fue confirmada de
que Ecuador había considerado la
posibilidad de enviar armamento y
hablando precisamente de la posición de
América Latina respecto a este conflicto
Lula da Silva quien está en el g7 se ha
planteado como uno de los posibles
mediadores en esta guerra también el
presidente rama fosa de Sudáfrica pero
sobre todo china no que es quizás quien
puede tener más posibilidades de sentar
a Rusia en la mesa de diálogo sin
embargo un delegado chino estuvo en kiev
esta semana y fue recibido por
dimitroculeva el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de Ucrania que le dijo que en
su país no estaba dispuesto a plantear
ninguna salida pacífica que supusiera la
cesión de territorio a Rusia entonces
les pregunto cómo se puede llegar a una
mediación en estos momentos y qué
actores el que más posibilidades tiene
de lograr una concesión por ambas partes
Enrique
Ojalá tuviera una respuesta para esa
pregunta yo creo que ahora mismo
la situación es poco propicia para un
diálogo y porque Lamento no no recordar
quién dijo esta frase hace no muchos
días pero
los dos bandos se ven con capacidad para
ganar esta guerra y cuando eso pasa No
es muy probable que haya una posibilidad
cierta de sentarse en una mesa los
intentos del enviado chino que estuvo
estos dos días en la capital ucraniana
no sea no ha trascendido demasiado sobre
Qué fue de esas reuniones sabíamos que
iba a seguir de gira por Europa por
varios países de Europa que iba a estar
también en Rusia pero tampoco hemos
conocido demasiado sobre esa visita que
insisto estaba envuelta en un cierto
misterio de hecho mientras el enviado
chino estuvo en Ucrania en la capital
los bombardeos rusos no han cesado de
hecho esta ha sido una semana
particularmente intensa en lo que a
bombardeo se refiere por parte de Rusia
yo la verdad no tengo muy claro Sí sí
tengo una certeza que ahora mismo no
estamos particularmente cerca de una
solución pacífica ni ni que ni siquiera
haya una posibilidad cierta de que se
sienten en una mesa al menos de manera
pública puede ser que a través de otros
canales de canales secundarios a través
de terceros Hay algún tipo de
negociación como ha habido para la
salida del cereal que se mantiene pero
por el momento yo mi sensación es que
eso es muy poco probable y que ambos
están preparando para para la
posibilidad cada vez más cierta de una
ofensiva Aprovechando que llega el buen
tiempo y que las condiciones del campo
de batalla son más favorables para ambos
bandos si Enrique y una de las
cuestiones que mantiene ambos bandos muy
alejados es la situación en crimea no
precisamente
ha reiterado esta semana su voluntad de
Recuperar el control sobre la Península
anexionada unilateralmente por Rusia en
2014 recordemos qué cree usted que los
aliados occidentales de Ucrania deberían
digamos incitar a hacer aquí eff
respecto a crimea que Rusia considera
totalmente su territorio ya
Bueno
lo que deben hacer los países
occidentales va a estar en todo caso
cuestionado o van a tener que poner en
una balanza dos cuestiones una ayudar a
Ucrania o ayudar a Ucrania lo que
Ucrania necesita pero sobre todo en no
dar a Rusia o en dar lo menos posible
Rusia porque ya no hay ninguna duda que
Rusia es el enemigo de buena parte de
Europa o de Europa hasta hace hasta
antes de esta guerra digamos había una
situación de una especie de calma tensa
pero ya cualquier cosa que se conceda
Ruiz a Rusia puede ser considerado una
derrota y sobre todo y aunque esto no lo
reconozcan las cancillerías europeas
puede sentar un precedente Porque si
rusa Rusia consigue lo que quiere o algo
de lo que quiere mediante una invasión
mediante un conflicto armado quién
garantiza que más adelante en un tiempo
el que sea pueda volver a tomar la misma
actitud para cualquier otra cosa
cualquier otra actividad porque
recordemos que al final Rusia envolvió
esta invasión en aquella eufemismo que
resultó una mentira de desgasificar
Ucrania pero en el fondo lo que había
era tratar de tomar el control de
Ucrania e impedir que Ucrania se
implicase en la comunidad internacional
en lo que se refiere refería a la Unión
Europea y a la otan Y ambos ambas
situaciones ambas circunstancias parecen
ahora más cercanas que Cuando comenzó
esta guerra Sí también sin embargo cada
vez se perfilan como decíamos no más
actores que podrían o que están
interesados en amear una paz entre ambos
países enfrentados veremos lo que sucede
en los próximos días y como usted decía
Enrique lo que continúa trascendiendo de
esta gira del hijo y el delegado chino
no para negociar con las partes de la
Que de momento no hemos conocido gran
cosa Les propongo cambiar de tema
nuevamente porque el pasado miércoles 17
de mayo se conmemoró la jornada
internacional contra la homofobia la
bifobia y la transfobia una fecha que
nos sirve de Marco para hablar de
derechos lgbti más en continente
americano Y empezamos en Estados Unidos
porque precisamente ese día fue el que
eligió el gobernador de Florida ron de
santis para promulgar la ley que prohíbe
los procedimientos médicos para menores
trans de santis eleva su perfil anti
derechos lgbt Como imagen ante su
esperada candidatura no a las primarias
republicanas de Cara a las
presidenciales de 2024 empiezo
preguntándole a usted Fabricio qué tanto
público tiene esta postura tan radical y
tan anti derechos en Estados Unidos del
esa postura yo creo que también hay que
de alguna manera compararla con lo que
está pasando en América Latina y por
ejemplo en mi país Aquí en el Ecuador el
Ecuador ha sido una discusión en los
últimos tiempos justamente el papel y la
visibilidad de los grupos lgbti en los
diversos temas de la vida pública acá
hasta
hace menos de 30 años había sido
considerado un delito la homosexualidad
finalmente fue despenalizada la
homosexualidad y hemos sido de alguna
manera caminando en función del
reconocimiento de los derechos de las
diversidades sexuales tal vez lo más
reciente lo más reciente hace un par de
años la corte constitucional yo paso a
la posibilidad del matrimonio
igualitario es decir el reconocer el
matrimonio civil entre personas del
mismo sexo lo que no se ha reconocido
hasta el momento es la posibilidad de
que esas personas que pudieron haberse
Unido en la unión de hecho entre
personas del mismo sexo eh puedan
adoptar es un tema que sigue siendo
materia de la pero los derechos de la
diversidad siguen siendo materia de de
análisis y de división entre la sociedad
aquí tenemos una sociedad que buena
parte es una sociedad conservadora
tenemos un presidente que tiene un corte
conservador eh Y seguramente de esto se
Se volverá a hablar a propósito de la
campaña electoral hace poco hubo algunas
manifestaciones por parte de la
comunidad lgbti que ha comenzado ya a
hablar del del mes del del Orgullo como
le llaman buscando reivindicaciones a
sus a sus derechos Ecuador todavía está
al azar O sea si comparamos con lo que
ha pasado en países como Argentina y
como Uruguay Ecuador Todavía está en el
camino en medio de tropiezos para lograr
ese reconocimiento total a las
comunidades y a las adversidades Sí y
Enrique le pregunto a usted Por qué
considera que todavía es objeto de
debate una cuestión como que el estado
garantice los derechos de todos sus
ciudadanos incluido de las personas lgbt
es una buena pregunta y es una pregunta
retórica más bien pero la verdad es que
no tiene no se puede entender que en
pleno Siglo 21
siga que haber reclamando los derechos
para la comunidad lgtbi es a lo que no
se puede entender puede haber debate
sobre muchas cosas pero Y eso creo que
es una marea que ya se está extendiendo
por todo el mundo y en que España Por
ejemplo ha sido pionera ha aprobado hace
poco una ley trans y fue uno de los
primeros países del mundo en aprobar una
ley de matrimonio homosexual que también
permite la adopción el gobierno de José
Luis Rodríguez zapatero El socialista
zapatero y quiero decir que esa marea
poco a poco va calando y va llegando y
va llegando hasta sociedades que son
Aparentemente más conservadoras pero
bien es cierto o si bien es cierto que
eso se está produciendo que hay cada vez
una extensión mayor de esos derechos y
de y de que entren en la agenda política
sin embargo eso no nos debe hacer perder
de vista que personajes como ron o
gobiernos como aquí en Europa el de
Hungría el ultraderechista Víctor Urban
son gobiernos que están apostando
firmemente Pues si bien por no
restringir derechos si bien por
acotarlos o de alguna manera no
ampliarlo Y eso es ciertamente peligroso
pero yo creo que
socialmente hay una percepción cada vez
más extendida de que de hacer normal lo
que es normal Eso era una frase que
decía un político español y en realidad
esas personas no pueden estar privadas
de derechos los ciudadanos no pueden
estar privados derechos con motivos de
su orientación sexual eso cada vez es
menos entendible en sociedades avanzadas
y democráticas en el siglo XXI y creo
que con el tiempo eso irá siendo
absolutamente insoslayable para
cualquier gobierno que se precie de ser
un gobierno democrático y Fabricio Para
volver a América Latina según el informe
de derechos lgbt en América Latina y el
Caribe una lucha inacabada de Andrés
Suárez de septiembre de 2022 se ha
publicado en Every entre 2014 y 2020 más
de 3.500 personas fueron asesinadas por
su orientación sexual o identidad de
género en la región que considera que se
debe hacer y qué discursos obstaculizan
qué discursos de odio obstaculizan aquí
en América Latina que se acabe con esta
agresión y con esta violencia
Me parece que mientras desde la clase
política desde la clase gobernante la
clase dirigente no se entienda que esta
es una discusión de derechos
independientemente de las convicciones
religiosas Morales como le llaman o
éticas que puedan tener no se comprenda
que esa es una institución de derechos
Lamentablemente vamos a seguir teniendo
esta panorámica que acaba usted de
señalar con estas estadísticas yo en
esas estadísticas Sí separo al Ecuador
el Ecuador hay un hay un fenómeno
todavía muchísimo más grave que tiene
que ver con los femicidios y esas
estadísticas son fortísimas es decir
mujeres asesinadas en muchos de los
casos por sus parejas no ocurre lo mismo
con miembros de la comunidad lgbti es
decir No le podemos poner en el mismo en
el mismo trato a mí me parece que la el
discurso oficial y el discurso de la
clase política tiene que evolucionar y
entender que este es un tema de derechos
por encima de sus propias convicciones
solamente en ese momento
acompañado de una verdadera política
pública que se puede entender ese tema
Las cosas creo yo podrían cambiar Bueno
Les propongo cerrar esta emisión con
otro tema de género y se ha desatado la
polémica esta semana precisamente porque
el actor Johnny Depp protagoniza La
película que abrió el festival de cine
de can la película llamada
El actor protagonizó recordemos un
juicio mediático mediatizado a nivel
mundial contra su expareja Amber Heart y
Depp recibió sin embargo una ovación en
la sala de proyecciones en can y
respondió a la prensa que no necesita
Hollywood en relación a las personas que
ya no lo quieren ver en la industria
estadounidense y que los que se
obsesionan con su vida son los que
tienen el problema les pregunto primero
a uno y después al otro empezamos por
usted Enrique Qué opinan de esta
aparición
bueno seguramente el asunto de mayor
trascendencia que ha sufrido la
industria audiovisual y el mundo del
cine en particular no solo el caso de
Johnny Depp sino todos los casos que
afectan a ese tipo de circunstancias con
el mitu etcétera etcétera en los últimos
años podíamos decir
yo La verdad no tengo una opinión clara
al respecto no tengo una opinión formada
al respecto en el caso en este en otros
puede ser que los tenga pero en este no
tanto me parece que
las circunstancias o lo que se cuenta
sobre esa relación era de una relación
tóxica y complicada pero al no haber
tenido por el momento Johnny del
reproche penal o no me consta que lo
haya tenido ciertamente es complicado y
luego volvemos a un debate que es un
debate que es inacabable y que no nace
con el mundo del cine y es la separación
entre la obra y el artista pueden
personas viles ser grandes artistas y
generar una producción artística
estimable No digo que sea yo ni de una
persona vil pero quiero decir ese es un
debate que está siempre y que
evidentemente está este festival de
cannes que es un festival que más allá
de Johnny Depp tiene un plantel de
estrellas invitadas absolutamente
estratosféricos como pocas veces se
había visto pero evidentemente el inicio
de este festival si bien la primera
mitad del festival la están ocupando
otros actores el inicio evidentemente lo
ha captado el propio Fabricio
rápidamente su opinión Yo creo que
un espacio mejor no lo podía encontrar
para su desaparición
yo debo decir que en algún momento ha
sido uno de mis de mis actores favoritos
yo soy seguidor de la saga de Piratas
del Caribe por ejemplo hizo el extraño
yo creo que este puede ser el inicio de
una suerte de reivindicación luego de
este conflicto Público de carácter
inclusive penal que él enfrentó y esta
relación tan tempestuosa con su pareja
veamos ir alcanza esto para volver
Hollywood ha dado muestras y el cine ha
dado muestras y hay artistas caídos que
luego regresan veamos si es el caso de
Johnny bueno veremos si les pregunto
para finalizar En qué van a tener el ojo
puesto la próxima semana recordemos que
este fin de semana la atención
internacional va a estar muy centrada en
el g7 en Hiroshima Japón ustedes
particularmente en qué van a tener en
sus tinteros Enrique
pues evidentemente lo que siga pasando
en Ucrania la situación entre Israel y
Palestina ha sido este pasado viernes un
nuevo viernes de tensión y lo que está
pasando lo que pueda pasar el fin de
semana en Italia que ha tenido unas
inundaciones muy importantes este fin de
esta semana pasada en la zona norte del
país está previsto que este fin de
semana vuelva a llover en una zona donde
los ríos ya están por encima del caudal
habitual y la posibilidad de que se
produzcan lluvias y de que vuelva a
producirse inundaciones y esperemos que
no víctimas mortales pues es uno de los
temas que hemos tratado esta semana
pasada y que seguramente seguirán la que
viene y muy preocupante la situación
climática en el sur de Europa y Fabricio
usted
igual la siguiente semana Será la
segunda semana después de que el
presidente de la república de Ecuador
disolviera la asamblea nacional hay que
estar expectantes de los posibles nuevos
decretos en materia económica se habla
también de la posibilidad de cambios en
su gabinete de ministros ha recibido el
apoyo internacional generado por parte
de algunos países el embajador de
Estados Unidos emitió justamente hace
pocas hace pocos días un par de días un
comunicado a través del cual la Casa
Blanca respaldaba al gobierno del
presidente lazo Por otra parte la
próxima semana el día 24 de mayo se
generará la convocatoria a las
elecciones anticipadas de presidente y
de asamblea nacional para el próximo 20
de agosto y un detalle adicional el 24
de mayo es un día de fiesta nacional en
el Ecuador se celebra un nuevo
aniversario de la batalla del pichincha
del 24 de mayo de 1822 y generalmente el
24 de mayo esta fecha en la que el
presidente de la república brinda su
informe a La Nación porque
cumplirá dos años Guillermo lasso en el
poder ese informe lo debía presentar
ante la asamblea nacional no hay
asamblea y lo va a presentar en en un
sector en una zona pública en un parque
acá en la capital de los Ecuatorianos Y
sí estará marcada la próxima semana
justamente aquí en el Ecuador Fabricio
pues estaremos muy atentos a sus notas
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en Front 24
Enrique Muchísimas gracias a usted
también por haber compartido su tiempo y
ese análisis aquí con nosotros Gracias
ha sido un placer y a ustedes Muchísimas
gracias por su atención Recuerden que
Pueden seguir con toda esta y más
información en 34 y Francia 4.com
[Música]